[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Simone de LaRue creator of body
by Simone here are five simple exercises
that are going to give you a full body
workout let's start off first with
cardio we're gonna do a jump squat this
is working our largest muscle groups in
our body so that's working out quads our
hamstring and our glutes and it's gonna
fire up our heart rate so that we're
really gonna get in our cardio fix for a
nice jump squat so you start down you
jump up in the air and lower down again
jump up and lower down jump up and lower
it down jump up and lower down and
squeeze yes you're gonna do three sets
of ten of those heart rate will be up
that is your cardio the next exercise
shoulder press we're working our
deltoids and our pecs I'm using a
resistance band the CLX band you can use
hand weights or you can use cans or
bottles of water come back down again
into your squat up to goal post reaching
up and down and up and down upper body
work up deltoids chest pull in those ABS
keep those shoulders down if you have
four hand weights pushing them up up
excellent we're also gonna do three sets
between ten and twelve reps third
exercise is the plank so we're going to
come back to our static plank elbows on
top of wrists I should say click back
tuck that little booty under
everything's engaged and hold I'm gonna
lower my back knee down and lift it up
my front knee down and lift it up and
both knees down and up and down again
back knee nothing's moving off my back
you can have a tray of cookies or tray
of champagne resting on there and they
will not spill and what's really working
into your lower abs and let's do one
more time perfectly still lower abs
lower abs both and both and up and rest
good three sets of 10 to 12 reps of
those especially going to feel that in
your lower abs next exercise booty yes
we want a nice shapely booty I'm gonna
use the resistance band again if you
don't have this you can use and do these
exercises without you can try putting an
ankle weight on or you can use this foot
in the loop
so I'm gonna do a kickback that's gonna
work into my hamstring and glute someone
coming into tabletop position kick my
leg up it's gonna go parallel against
the resistance my foot is flexed my leg
is parallel bring that knee in to my
navel and I kick straight back into
navel straight back good without the
resistance band same exercise try an
ankle weight straight back good for that
one we're gonna do two sets of 20 reps
on each leg
and now for our outer and inner thigh so
our abductors and adductors line up
elbow underneath shoulder extend both
legs pull up up that waist if you have
any shoulder issues you can do this
laying down if not stay up and we're
gonna work heave lift the top leg up
outer thigh this underneath leg is the
working one this is the tricky one you
come underneath it click that heel place
it down and lower down so we do lift and
squeeze and down and down lift and
squeeze you want to keep those legs
parallel you want to make sure that your
hips are stacked on top of each other
and that your navels drawing towards
your spine and you're just lifting the
leg ticket pipe parallel and pointed
those heels down and up abduction
abduction good and those will also be
two sets of 20 reps on each side so
those five exercises should take you
about 15 to 20 minutes in length to do
them and remember we don't want to speed
through it we want to use correct
technique and correct form because
that's the way you see results good luck